[Applause]
good morning the uh this is going to be
very easy because the topic is do we
have the will to defeat Isis or the
Islamic State and obviously the answer
is no so enjoy your
breakfast but uh there are actually some
reasons for that and very simply in the
first place in order to defeat the
Islamic State air strikes alone are not
going to do it in the history of areial
warfare it has never been known that a
country was conquered solely from the
air and the Islamic state is going to be
no exception they're going to have to be
significant Ground Forces nobody wants
to send Ground Forces back to Iraq and
even if we did send Ground Forces back
to Iraq we would probably make the same
mistakes we made the first time in
engaging in wilsonian nation building
projects instead of actually trying to
win the war and the whole thing would be
for doomed the uh idea that Wars are to
be fought in order to Aid the enemy
instead of to defeat the enemy is
actually a New Concept that has come
about in the last few decades and is
really at the core of the problem of why
the West at this point does not have the
will to defeat the Islamic
State the core of the concept was
actually summed up I think recently in a
New York Times piece that was called 27
ways to be a modern
man and it was a wonderful piece because
you know the New York Times of course is
the adjudicator of acceptable opinion
the Arbiter of style and the guide for
the perplexed and they set it all out
for us what does it mean to be a modern
man and I thought well you know I want
to be a modern man I'm going to read
this and so I found out actually that uh
the Modern Man listens to Wu Tang at
least at least once a week now I had to
look that up I
uh I found out actually that wuang is an
American hipop group from New York City
originally composed of east coast
rappers rzaa gz Method Man rayquan
Ghostface Killer inspect a deck you God
Mast teilla kidana and the late Old
Dirty
Bastard now of course there plenty of us
still alive but the late Old Dirty
Bastard is somebody who I think sums up
a lot of the problem here that modern
man doesn't seem to care about the
societal Decay that his musical tastes
represent modern man doesn't seem to
have much of any moral compass and one
of the things that were also told by the
New York Times about the modern man is
that he has no use for a gun he does not
own one and does not need one and I
thought well how how does Modern I
understand that he might not want to own
one but how does Modern Man know that he
doesn't ever need
one because he even says the modern man
lies on the side of the bed closer to
the door if an intruder gets in he will
try to fight him off so that his wife
has a chance to get away well it's
interesting enough that modern man has a
wife at all
but he has no use for a gun so how
exactly is he going to fight off this
guy well we understand that uh the
modern man always has a melon baller on
hand to make sure that his cantaloupe
watermelon and honeydew are uniformly
shaped and So that obviously he can use
to fight off the
Intruder the Modern Men also were told
cries he cries
often and I think uh one of the reasons
why there's going to be more and more
crying in the west is because modern man
is in charge of the United States
government at this time Barack Obama is
a modern man John G is a modern man and
the core assumption in all seriousness
is that they think we're beyond all that
we're Beyond Wars we're Beyond fighting
there is no conflict in the world that
cannot be solved by sitting down and
negotiating because everybody else is a
modern man as well see that's why the
modern man doesn't need a gun because if
the guy comes in with a gun they can
just sit down and talk about it and
they'll reach some Accord and they
really believe that this is true
Barack Obama and John krey showed that
they were quintessential Modern Men when
they thought well we the Ayatollah K
he's somebody just like us well sure he
shouts death to America a few times but
really he he he has the same aspirations
for peace the same desire to join the
the the harmonious community of Nations
and so we can do business and they
did the biggest obstacle that the Modern
Man faces however is that there are some
people in the world who are not Modern
Men K of course is one very much so and
the uh leader of North Korea the cff of
the Islamic State all of them
old-fashioned
guys and old-fashioned guys they
understand that there is tribalism there
is there ancient hatreds there is
Warfare and there are some things that
you just can't settle by means of
talking things out now what's very
interesting nowadays is that we see the
confrontation of the modern man with the
old-fashioned man in many many Arenas
nowadays and it's always a very
interesting confrontation for example
there is a very courageous individual
Canon Andrew White he's known as the
Vicor of Baghdad and he has is an
Anglican clergyman from the UK who has
remained in Baghdad and in Iraq as it
has become a war zone and as the
Christians have been victimized by the
hundreds of thousands and he has stayed
there but Canon white showed the other
day that he still has a bit of modern
man in him because he contacted the
leaders of Isis as they were getting
close to Baghdad and invited them to
dinner and you know I I thought wouldn't
that be amazing if Winston Church Hill
had written to Hitler and said hey come
on to dinner but of course Neville
Chamberlain did just that he he accepted
Hitler's invitation and went to Munich
Neville Chamberlain was a modern man
Churchill understood there no talking to
this guy there is no talking to him that
is going to solve anything and we're
just going to have to go to war but
Canon white he invited the leaders of
the Islamic State to dinner and they
very graciously responded we'll be glad
to come to dinner and we'll cut off your
head that's the confrontation between
Modern Man and the old-fashioned man the
another one that was uh very interesting
just the other day was in regard to
fisel Muhammad fisel Muhammad is a young
man was a young man who on the
University of California mered Campus he
just recently stabbed four people and
seriously wounded them and uh it has
come out that he left a Manifesto that
has not yet been published in full but
we have heard that in the manifesto he
praised Allah and he had a stepbystep uh
plan for what he was going to do when he
carried out the stabbings including to
sit down and sing the Praises of Allah
after he' carried out the stabbings and
that uh it has been further revealed by
a television station in mered itself
that he was on a terror watch list and
had an Isis flag in his
possession and Vern wary who is a police
investigator in Merced at this time said
he conceded these facts and then said
but this has nothing to do with his
religion this has nothing to do with
Islam whatsoever he killed he stabbed
these people didn't kill anybody he
stabbed these people because he was
disgruntled about being uh kicked out of
a study group and that's all it's about
now that's quintessential Modern Man the
modern man is not annoyed by reality he
is not troubled by reality reality is
not something that the modern man is
interested in at all but here again in
reality keeps impinging upon who he is
and what he wants to
do just a few days ago also in hem traic
Michigan
near Detroit the for the first time in
the history of the United States a
majority Muslim city council was elected
in ham traik and all the while that the
Muslim candidates were running this was
celebrated as something that would be a
Triumph of diversity in
multiculturalism so as soon as they were
elected at the at the celebration party
one of the new city councilmen in hem
traik said we showed the Polish and
everybody else hem traic having been a
historically polish City and this sent
shock waves through the local community
and people said a lot of the people
including some of the defeated
candidates said well you know he's
speaking in a way that's not really
consistent with diversity and
multiculturalism he shouldn't be wanting
to show the Polish or show them up or or
rebuke them in any way we're all working
together in harmony here aren't we well
no but that's what happens when Modern
Man meets reality now the disjunction I
think is society-wide between reality
and the modern man you take for example
Ben Carson and Barack Obama and Ben
Carson recently of course ignited a
firestorm by saying that he wouldn't
want to see a Muslim president and lots
of people said wait a minute he doesn't
even know the Constitution there's no
religious test for the for candidates in
the Constitution and he ought to be
aware of that he wasn't saying that
however this was a misinterpretation
probably willful of his words what he
was pointing out was that Islam law
Sharia has numerous aspects that are
incompatible with constitutional
freedoms denies the freedom of speech
denies the freedom of conscience denies
the equality of Rights of women denies
the equality of Rights of non-muslims
these things obviously are not
compatible with constitutional
principles such that as Dr Carson
pointed out a presidential candidate if
he were a Muslim would have to either
adhere to the Constitution or
Sharia but not he couldn't do both and
he would have to renounce aspect of
sharia in order to adhere to
constitutional principles and he might
be doing that honestly or dishonestly
and this is a this is a problem that is
probably going to recur and of course
this was a terrible thing and Dr Carson
was widely denounced as an
islamophobe now on the on the other hand
you have Barack Obama who of course has
said Muslims are part of the fabric of
this nation and have contributed to it
since its founding and of course you
remember all the Muslim generals and the
Revolutionary War and the Muslims among
the founding fathers the Muslim signers
of the Declaration of Independence and
so on and so we have to admit he has a
point But Here Again modern man is
untroubled by
reality and the idea that Barack Obama
could say that and could say the future
must not belong must not belong to those
who slander the prophet of Islam which
is a direct attack on the First
Amendment a direct attack on the freedom
of speech and on the idea that even if
something is considered to be slander of
the prophet of Islam American ought to
be free to say it that ought to have
ignited the Firestorm but of course
there was nothing because Modern Men is
in control of the mainstream media as
well as in control of the government and
so what all this makes clear in brief is
that what we need in the government of
the United States as we approach the new
election cycle are some old-fashioned
men and women who understand that we're
not beyond all that at all and and that
modern man going into the confrontation
with the ancient old-fashioned men
represented by the caleff Al baghdaddy
and Ayatollah K and so on is absolutely
outmanned is absolutely outclassed and
has no chance of defeating him as a
matter of fact of course defeat is not
even something that he's interested in
pursuing you may recall as a matter of
fact that we went into Afghanistan 13
years ago or 12 years ago in order to
defeat the Taliban
and now the Pentagon and the United
States government are announcing that
the Taliban are an integral part an
important aspect of the post-war
situation and the new harmonious and
peaceful
Afghanistan can you imagine if we had
said well we have to have the Nazis in
the post World War II German government
but of course Modern Men weren't in
charge during World War II and what we
have to do is turn them out now and
insist
that we elect people who are patriotic
and who are aware of reality who are
aware of the reality of the Islamic
Jihad against the West who are aware of
the reality of Islamic law and the
implications that that has for the
American poity as well as for
international relations and people who
will take these real take confront these
facts realistically and formulate
strategy on the basis of them rather
than as Barack Obama and John krey and
all the other Modern Men are trying to
do reshape reality into the image that
they wish it to be the Glorious
Multicultural future in which there's no
nationality and no boundaries and no
standards for anything and we're all
just together in this one glorious
Mosaic it's uh
unfortunately true that when these kinds
of fantasies are applied to reality then
disaster ensues and that is what we are
unfortunately heading for unless we get
the modern man out of office and so that
should be our primary objective for 2016
thank
you that was great Robert thank you Nina
I wanted to ask is um Jihad watch going
to do like a compendium of kind of
um how you say grave missteps in the
same regard as you just
documented the the conflict with the
First Amendment to get sort of the
contrast out there yeah that's a good
idea thank you and I think absolutely so
yes uh I people aren't aware of the
nature of Islamic law and it's widely
off fiscated you know a few years back
there was there were Nationwide uh and
Nationwide attempts to Outlaw Sharia in
various States and the uh Council on
American Islamic relations the Islamic
advocacy group with links to the to
Hamas and the Muslim Brotherhood they uh
fought fiercely against these
initiatives and were able to get
activist judges to overturn them where
they were passed in most of the places
where they were passed now they said
that you can't Outlaw Sharia because
Sharia is simply Islamic religious law
and so you would be forbidding Muslims
to practice Islam and this was taken as
as as axiomatic by the judges who
overturned these statutes but obviously
the point needs to be made people aren't
concerned about Sharia because Muslims
are reading the Quran on or getting
married According to Islamic rights or
something of that kind or putting
setting out their Wills in accord with
Islamic law and so on nobody's concerned
about that people are only concerned
about Islamic law about Sharia in so far
as it does conflict with the principles
and the and the freedoms that are
guaranteed in the US Constitution and so
that ought to be the focus of these
anti-sharia initiatives and I hope that
they'll be able to be revived on that
basis
that was really brilant um Robert um I'm
wondering since all of us in this room
are not modern men and women but
dinosaurs proud dinosaurs and the andral
I'm wondering um as a case study since
you're one of us you're one of the
dinosaurs and you're a very brave one
what it um what care and other
organizations have personally done to
you and whether or not you have had
fatwas put out on your head or fatwas
put out in your head and how you've
managed to deal with that well yeah I
have a lot of death threats in terms of
that I don't know if I have any formal
thought was but uh death threat is a
death threat you know whether it's got
an official stamp from a Muslim cleric
or not um I'm not concerned about death
threats I mean obviously I travel with
uh I mean if I'm speaking in a public
place where they're likely to
be where it's been announced and they're
likely to be people who are just coming
in from uh wherever then I generally
have security with me and uh the great
Floyd is right here and uh
that's that's always a consideration but
I'm not really concerned about it's not
as if I'm going to be immortal if I
don't do this work and so at a certain
point you just have to make a decision
to go ahead as far as care goes it's
much more important what care does is
and it's not only with me but anybody
anyone and everyone who speaks the truth
about these issues care will Target and
try to discredit and silence and
marginalize and they have done this for
years such that they tar with the
charges of racism bigotry and
islamophobia anyone who speaks about
this in any forum and I see it all the
time I get the care mailing every day
and they are asking somebody some place
to cancel some speaker or asking that
some City officer somewhere resign
because he wrote something anti-muslim
on his Facebook page and the anti-muslim
statement was really about how we need
to resist the jihadis but of course care
tries to obstruct that the idea is to
intimidate Americans into silence and
make people afraid to speak out about
this because they think well I don't
want to be charged with racism and
bigotry and so I'll just keep quiet
about this and it's been an
extraordinarily effective campaign the
fort dick Jihad plot their six Albanian
Muslims were going to go into Fort Dicks
and shoot as many American soldiers as
possible before they themselves were
killed and went to the virgins that was
foiled by a 17-year-old boy because he
was working in a video store and the
jihadis went into the video store and
they asked him to transfer all their
gory Jihad tapes from VHS to
DVD and so he was watching all this and
he he he he was alarmed but this is the
key point he went to his manager and he
said
dude I'm watching all this weird stuff
on the screen should I go to the police
or would that be
racist would that be racist see that I
think sums up right there where he's
worried would it be racist to turn in
some bloodthirsty jihadis to the police
that shows how how how successful the
care campaign has been that this
teenager he's internalized all that next
question is right here Robert
thank you for your analysis of of the
character because this is something that
our enemies always do we always used to
read about how the Soviets paid so much
attention to what our leaders were like
and indeed Putin has done that for Obama
he is inside his head as somebody said
and we never do ite and that was a
really perfect thing using that modern
man um thank you one thing one thing I
want to ask you about is tribalism
connected with that because one of the
Great achievements of Mo not modern man
but modern civilization in America is
that we have tried to overcome tribalism
we pursued
integration you know we broaden rights
to everybody and it seems to me that
what our Modern Men and and uh the left
is doing is to bring back tribalism so
when those jihadis said we got the
Polish that just seems like an omen of
things to come you know if you were
always attacked for who you are you're
going to be tribal after a while yeah
absolutely I think well of course the
many people have observed that the
multiculturalist imperative is all
cultures are equal except our own and
all cultures are good except
judeo-christian Western culture which is
to be rejected and and despised in every
possible way and so the idea of
multiculturalism does encourage
tribalism because it ENC it encourages
you to take on your cultural identity
even and especially in the west and
especially in the US at the expense of
the mainstream culture and so yeah
there's no way that this can at a
certain point it where it's going to
result in atomization and conflict
there's no way that it can't it's just
uh like Austria Hungary the austr
Hungarian Empire with all its
constituent nationalities and the more
that they began to press for their
National identities the more it became
inevitable that the empire was going to
dissolve and these constituent Parts
would be independent now in the United
States it's going to be actually much
Messier and bloodier because it's not a
regional thing or a national or or or or
a a matter of different nationalities
together in one but these different
cultural identities that are being
reinforced and often in a manner that is
quite hostile to the mainstream so yes
it's not going to end
well question the back hold on robt
[Music]
thank you is there enough drive or
purpose behind the movement to get the
Muslim Brotherhood designated as a
terrorist organization well the purpose
is to stop the Obama Administration from
favoring the Muslim Brotherhood the
Obama administration's solicitude for
the Muslim Brotherhood is so extreme
that when the Muslim Brotherhood regime
in Egypt was being toppled by the
Egyptian people millions and millions of
Egyptians out on the streets
demonstrating against the Brotherhood
regime in 2013
they were holding up signs saying Obama
stopped supporting
terrorists and it was all about Obama's
supporting the Muslim Brotherhood even
after the Brotherhood regime has been
toppled he has met with Brotherhood
representatives in Washington and sent
American Representatives over to speak
to the Brotherhood in Cairo while
snubbing and giving the cold shoulder to
the aisi regime that is against the
Brotherhood so the idea of designating
the Muslim Brotherhood a terror group
would be to try to end this Muslim
Brotherhood influence and the decided
pro- Muslim Brotherhood slant of the
Obama Administration excuse me okay
right here right here
where so I was in class and I was
defending Dr Carson's statements because
the United States was founded on
judeo-christian values and not Islamic
values and I had a teacher tell me that
judeo-christian was a term made up to
get votes from Republican
Christians uh is is that the case uh
which I I know it's not but but uh how
could I defend against that in class
well you point out that uh that you can
there are people you can point to who
were Jews and who were Christians who
really were participating in the
founding of the United States and that
there were Jews who were participating
in the American Revolution right from
the beginning as a matter of fact there
was a very significant I believe his
name was Haim Solomon a very significant
figure in the uh political career of
George Washington and the ability of the
Continental Army to sustain itself was
this uh supporter who was Jewish and so
you have Jews and Christians from the
beginning of the United States you don't
have any Muslims there contrary to
Obama's fantasy so the idea that there
is something newly minted and
manipulative about or propagandistic
about the judeo-christian label is
simply uh flying in the face of the
facts there really has been Jewish and
Christian cooperation and a a a a a
congruence in seeing the principles of
the United States as worth founding and
worth defending and a Jewish and
Christian presence here obviously all
through the history of the United States
and Jews having been persecuted all over
the world found this to be the most
welcoming Nation probably in the history
of the world for the Jewish people
whereas Muslims were never present here
at all and when they came here have been
supremacist and antagonistic from the
beginning in demanding special
privileges and so on that uh other
groups are not accorded
so uh you're the the claim that your
professor is making is just more of this
ahistorical Modern Man fantasy really
okay this this will have to be the last
question
okay well it's not a question just an
add-on to an excellent
observation uh there were of course
synagogues during the colonial times and
the first uh um mosque in the United
States was established when does anybody
know anybody in the room room no
1928 Omaha first mosque first synagogues
Washington George Washington times thank
you very much thank you thank you very
much